اهلا بكم اصدرت خمس دول غربيه بيانا ترفض
فيه التدخل الخارجي في ليبيا وتحذر من
تداعياته وذلك بعد يوم من نقل صحيفه
نيويورك تايمز عن مسؤولين امريكيين قولهم
ان طائره اماراتيه قصفت مواقع في طرابلس
بدعم مصري نتوقف مع هذا الخبر نناقشه في
محورين ما دلاله اقدام الامارات ومصر على
قصف مواقع داخل ليبيا دون التنسيق مع
الدول
الغربيه وما تداعي ذلك في الوقت الذي ترفض
فيه دول الجوار والاطراف الدوليه التدخل
في
ليبيا اصدرت خمس دول غربيه وهي الولايات
المتحده وبريطانيا وفرنسا والمانيا
وايطاليا بيانا ترفض فيه التدخل الخارجي
في ليبيا وتحذر من انه سيزيد في تعميق
الانقسامات الداخليه وتقويض عمليه
الانتقال الديمقراطي في ليبيا ياتي ذلك
بعد يوم من تصريح مسؤولين امريكيين لصحيفه
نيويورك تايمز بان دوله الامارات ومصر
نسقت فيما بينهما لشن عمليه قصف جوي في
طرابلس لم يعد السؤال حول الجهه التي قصفت
جو مواقع للثوار في العاصمه الليبيه
طرابلس مرتين خلال اسبوع فقد اكدت قوات
فجر ليبيا ان مصر والامارات قامت بذلك
الامريكيون سريعا ما اكدوا الامر سربوا
اخبارا لصحف تتمتع بمصداقيه عاليه لم
تكتفي بتاكيد ضلوع الدولتين بل عبرت عن ما
هو اكثر من الاستياء وهو الغضب من عدم
ابلاغهم مسبقا ما جعل السؤال ليس من انقصف
بل لماذا ليبيا كان واضحا ان هدف القصف
الاول وقف تقدم قوات فجر ليبيا في معركه
المطار بعد الحاقهم الهزيمه بقوات حفتر
هناك وفي القصف الثاني كانت ثمه رغبه
بالانتقام من النصر الذي احرز وفي
الحالتين انتهى التدخل الجوي الى فشل
تتعدى تداعياته محيط ليبيا الى الاقليم
وعلاقاته بالجوار الغربي هنا تكتسب الصوره
تعقيدا لم يتحسب له من خطط وامر وقصف وفي
ظنه ربما ان الانسحاب الامريكي من المنطقه
يبيح ويتيح التحرك منفردا وان علاقات
التحالف تسمح بذلك غضا للنظر على الاقل
لكن موقع ليبيا الجيوسياسي المعقد جعل
ويجعل التدخل فيها ذا كلفه ثقيله لا تقتصر
على محيطها العربي ما يوجب موقفا امريكيا
يكبح ويمنح تحول التدخل الى قنبله قد
تنفجر في وجوه الجميع ف جوار ليبيا
الاوروبي لا يرغب في انفلات الفوضه
الامنيه هناك الى شواطئه مهاجرين غير
شرعيين وربما اعمال عنف وتهريب سلاح ما
يفسر ربما باثر رجعي تردد اوباما نفسه في
التدخل عسكريا ضد القدافي الازمه اذا في
صفوف من قصف فصاحب التعبير الذي غاد شائعا
وملتبسة
العكس ففيها مئات الالاف من العماله
المصريه التي دفعت وتدفع ثمن مسعى قيادتها
للتدخل ناهيك عن تعارض هذا المسعى مع
بيئات اقليميه ودوليه تعارض هذا التدخل من
الاساس نظرا ل تبعاته الامنيه والانسانيه
فلا تونس ترغب ولا حتى الجزائر وهما جوار
ليبي في تدخل يفاقم ازمات المنطقه ما يجعل
السؤال مشرعا ومشروعا حول ما ان كان القصف
تصرفا منعزلا ام مقدمه لمغامر في رمال
متحركه تبتلع كل من يضع اقدامه
فيها موضوع حلقتنا نناقشه مع ضيوفنا حيث
ينضم الينا من طرابلس صلاح الدين طباق
المحامي والناشط السياسي من واشنطن مارك
ليفين كبير الباحثين في مشروع ترومان
للامن القومي وعبر الهاتف من الاسكندريه
الدكتور حسن نافعه استاذ العلوم السياسيه
في جامعه القاهره ابدا معك دكتور حسن ما
الذي دفع القاهره وابو ظبي الى هذا التدخل
والى هذه الخطوه
الانفراديه يعني المصدر الذي اتمتم عليه
يعني في هذا الامر هو النيويورك تايمز
ونيويورك تايمز تحدثت
عن دخول دول عديده على خط الازمه في ليبيا
منها قطر التي قالت انها تزود بعض الاطراف
طيب دعني ايضا اضيف الى مصادرك الدكتور
حسن فقط سادع تكم ولكن فقط الان تاكيد من
الخارجيه ومن وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه لهذا
الخبر اي قيام كل من القاهره وابو ظبي
بالتدخل اي الموضوع موضوع حلقتنا لهذه
الليله
تفضل الخبر يقول سواء كان من نيويورك
تايمز او من وزاره الخارجيه ان طائرات
اماراتيه قصفت وانها استخدمت
المطارات المصريه يعني المصادر الامريكيه
هي الوحيده حتى هذه اللحظه التي اكدت هذا
الخبر وفي الوقت نفسه اذا كان الاعتماد
على النيويورك تايمز فال النيويورك تايمز
يعني اكدت في الوقت نفسه ذكرت دول اخرى
تتدخل في الازمه الليبيه منها قطر التي
قالت انها تزود اطراف اسلاميه بالمال
والسلاح وبالتالي هي طرف في هذه الازمه
واذا صح ما قالته نيويورك تايمز وما قالته
بعض المصادر الامريكيه الرسميه ان هناك
اطراف عربيه تتدخل في الازمه سواء بالمال
والسلاح لبعض الاطراف او من خلال تقديم
تسهيلات المطارات كما حدث مع مصر او قيام
طائرات بالقصف كما كما هي كما حال
الطائرات الاماراتيه فهذا معناها طيب ماذا
عن سؤال دكتور حسن ماذا عن سؤالي ما الذي
دفع القاهره وابو ظبي للقيام بهذه الخطوه
وقطر لماذا لا تضد قطر ايضا ما دخل قطر في
هذا
الموضوع قيل ان قطر تزود اطراف ليبيه
بالمال والسلاح وبالتالي هي جزء من الازمه
الممتده اي ان الدول طيب دعني دعني اعيد
دعني اعيد صياغه سؤالي ما الذي دفع
القاهره وابو ظبي الى التدخل بشكل مباشر
فيما يجري في الشان الليبي وليس عن طريق
وكلاء ايا كان الطرف تتهمه طرف ثالث او
رابع او
خامس بشكل مباشر يعني انا يعني ما فهمت ان
الطائرات هي طائرات اماراتيه وان مصر قدمت
تسهيلات من المطارات فقط وبالتالي انا لا
استطيع ان ان اؤكد او انفي هذا الخبر الذي
مصدره امريكي ولكن الخبر بكامله يقول ان
هناك اطراف
عربيه يعني منغمسه في الازمه الليبيه
بعضها بالمال والسلاح وبعضها بالتدخل
المباشر من خلال القصف الجوي ومصر قدمت
تسهيلات لوجستيه في هذا الامر السؤال يجب
ان يطرح وبامانه شديده لماذا تتدخل كل هذه
الاطراف هل اص هو سؤال قبل ذلك قبل دكتور
حسن سؤال قبل ذلك لماذا الى الان لا ابو
ظبي ولا القاهره نفت الموضوع بشكل
قطعي انا ليس لدي معلومات لماذا نفذ هذا
الموضوع ولكن اي تدخل في
الشان الداخلي لاي دوله هو امر غير مرو
مشروع بطبيعه الحال سواء كان تدخلا بشكل
مباشر او بشكل غير مباشر وبالتالي يتعين
على كل الاطراف الا تنغمس في الازمات
الداخليه وان تترك اطراف الازمه الداخليين
يعالجوا ازماتهم بانفسهم وبالتالي من
منظور القانون الدولي اي تدخل في الشان
الداخلي لدوله اخرى هو مساله غير مشروعه
سواء كان هذا هذا عن المبدا هذا عن دكتور
حسن سيد مارك ليفن ضيفي من واشنطن ما
تفسير قيام ابو ظبي والقاهره بهذه الخطوه
بدون تنسيق مع جهات
اجنبيه اعتقد ان هذا الامر يظهر ان الرئيس
اوباما رفع يده من اي دور مباشر له في
ليبيا وبصراحه في الشرق الاوسط اعتقد انه
بعد ذهابنا الى ليبيا وبدعم غربي وفي
الوقت الذي كان يهدد فيه القذافي باحداث
مجزره ضد الشعب الليبي كان هنالك دعم عام
بين الغرب وبين الدول العربيه والشعب
الليبي من اننا يجب ان نوقف هذه المجره
التي كان يهدد القيام بها القذافي لكن
الموقف الان ازداد تعقيدا هنالك ميليشيات
تحاول ان تفرض سيطرتها على المناطق وهنالك
تدخل من حكومات عديده هنالك قطر وتركيا
تدعمان الاسلاميين وايضا لدينا مصر وال
الامارات تدعم الجنرال حفتر واعتقد ان
وجهه النظر الامريكيه يجب ان يبتع ال عن
التدخل ويجب ان لا يكون هنك حرب بالوكاله
كان هنالك انتخابات مؤخرا قبل اشهر دعوا
الحكومه تلعب دورها ودعو الشعب الليبي
يقرر مصيره بدون هذه التدخلات
الخارجيه والامر الذي ينتج عنه معاناه
الشعب الليبي سيد صلاح الدين طباق ما الذي
خلفته او خلفه هذا التدخل في المزاج
الليبي في الشارع الليبي سواء بمختلف
اطيافه وتوجهاته ومع من
يقف
هو تحيه طيبه لك استاذ محمد ول السده
المشاهدين اود بدايه ان نوضح بان هناك
تلبيس يحدث فيما يتعلق بال التيار السياسي
او الفريق او الطيف الذي يقود عمليه فجر
ليبيا بكونه اسلام سياسي
وان الامر
منوط الاخوان المسلمين اقول لك وانا من
ارض الحدث على الواقع هناك تيار ممتد مدن
وا اطراف وطنيه وغيرها من مختلف التيارات
الفكريه والسياسيه تنتمي الى هذه العمليه
ولذلك اتصور بان تصويرها بعلى انها تيار
اسلام سياسي مقابل تيار علماني هو قول غير
صحيح م ع عقه بافا عفوا سيد طبق عندي عندي
فقط نقطه نظام بالنسبه لضيوفي في الثلاثه
البعض يشير الى دول اخرى البعض يشير تحميل
ايضا المسؤوليه وانت تتحدث عن مساله توصيف
موضوعنا في هذه الحلقه فقط ينحصر في مساله
الاتهامات الموجهه لكل من الامارات
العربيه المتحده ومصر وما تسرب عن طريق
نيويورك تايمز وتداعيات هذه الخطوه فقط
لان الوقت ضيق ولا يتسع المجال لكل
هذه التوسعات في الموضوع
تفضل نعم استاذ محمد اعود هناك قرارات
امميه
بالخصوص الشعب
الليبي يعني عقب ثورته تكفلت المنظومه
الامميه
بصيانه وحمايه سيادته بمقتضى قرارات امميه
ذات ذات علاقه بالخصوص فاذا به يصم يصطدم
يعني يفاجا و
يعني يحدث له وقع الصدمه
بتدخل دول جوار ودول ابعد من الجو وار في
اصفاف سياسي لمصلحه هذا الفريق ضدك وال
الشارع
الليبي لا يقبل مطلقا تدخل الغير في شانه
الداخلي
لدينا يعني ردود افعال بعضها يعني في طور
التكوين تطالب باتخاذ
جمله تصرفات قبل الدول التي قامت بالتدخل
السافر وانتهاك السياده الليبيه سواء
باعمال مسلحه او بغير الاعمال المسلحه
سواء باللجوء الى مجلس الامن الدولي
والمطالبه بتطبيق القرارات واحترام
القرارات ذات العلاقه اخرها القرار
2144 الصادر في مارس 2014 والذي يؤكد بشكل
صريح ودقيق على حمايه وصيانه السياده
الوطنيه ايضا هناك اطراف تدعو الى اجراء
تحقيق فيما يتعلق بالسلاح الذي استخدم
ومعلوماتهم لا تقول بان
هناك صاروخ او صاروخان لم ينفجر وهناك
فريق قانوني يشتغل على هذا الموضوع في
مطالبه للجهه المصنعه على اساس من قامت
بتوريدها الجهه التي قامت بتوريدها والجهه
ومن ثم يمكن تاكيد الجهه التي استخدمتها
ايضا هناك بعض الاراء المتطرفه فيما يتعلق
بالشارع الليبي تقول بانه يجب اتخاذ بعض
المواقف من الدول التي قامت
بانتهاك السياده والاعتداء المباشر على
الليبيين كما ذكرت لك
سالفا اط تيار سياسي دكتور دكتور حسن
نافعه كيف لنا ان نفهم الموقف المصري
اجتماع القاهره دول الجوار يخرج بعدم
التدخل في ليبيا اجتماع الدول الخمس ال
غربيه يدعو الى عدم التدخل في ليبيا ومع
ذلك يتم التدخل عسكريا في ليبيا اما
باستعمال قواعد عسكريه للسماح بالطائرات
الاماراتيه بالمرور كما قال الخبر في
نيويورك تايمز او بصيغ
اخرى يعني طبعا يجب ان نعود بالذاكره الى
الوراء قليلا
لان ليبيا تحولت الى مصدر تهديد اود ان
اذكر الساده المشاهدين ان عددا من
المصريين قتم في ليبيا وبالذات مسيحيين
وان بعض الميليشيات المسلحه عسكريا هي
التي قامت بقتلهم دون قبل ان يحدث اي تدخل
من اي نوع من جانب السلطه المصريه وهذا
يشكل اعتداء مباشر على المصريين في ليبيا
ايضا يعني بعض الفصائل جعل اشرت الى هذه
المساله الا تساهم وتعطي المبرر تدخل مصري
عسكري في ليبيا يعطي المبرر اكثر للاعتداء
على مئات الالاف من المصريين المقيمين في
ليبيا الاعتداء يا سيدي تم قبل ان تتدخل
مصر وبالتالي كان هناك تهديد لحياه
المصريين اصلا وبعض الدول لا تحتمل حتى
مجرد ان يقتل لها شخص واحد وتتدخل فورا
لمجرد ان يقتل شخص اذا هذا يبرر لمصر ان
تقف مع فريق في اتجاه فريق اخر او ضد فريق
اخرست مع انا لست مع اي تدخل لكني يعني
اعرض فقط للسياقات الدوليه التي يصبح فيها
التدخل مشروعا بشكل او باخر عندما يحدث
اعتداء على
مواطنين داخل دوله اخرى فطبعا يعني يوجد
مبرر للتدخل لكن ليس بالضروره تدخل عسكري
يمكن ان يكون التدخل بشكل دبلوماسي اذا
كان هناك امكانيه لحل الاشكاليه لكن من
الواضح ان ليبيا تحولت الى مصدر تهديد
لمصر وق جرائم ارتكبت داخل الاراضي
المصريه وقيل ان هناك ارهابيين دخلوا من
الحدود الليبيه واقترف هذه الجرائم هناك
تسليح يعني اسلحه تخترق الحدود
هناك يعني امور كثيره جدا تهدد الامن
الوطني المصري وهناك من يتصور ان ما حدث
في مصر لجماعه الاخوان المسلمين يستدعي
انتقاما من جانب هذه الفصائل بالتالي هي
ترد على ما ما تعتبر انه انقلاب عسكري او
تحاول مقاومه هذا الانقلاب بطريقتها هناك
ايضا امور كثيره
تستوجب يعني يشعر النظام المصري بان حياه
المصريين في وان كانت حلقتنا دكتور حسن
فقط هي لا تبحث لا تبحث في مبررات كل طرف
ولكن في الفعل في حد ذاته اي ماجرى وقيام
طائرات با اجنبيه بقصف في داخل العاصمه
يعني تريد ان ت كل ما حدث قبل ذلك وتركز
على هذا ال وتعتبر ان المسالتين منفصلتين
تماما هل هذا
معقول على كل فاصل قصير نناقش بعده نرجو
ان تبقوا
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد في هذه الحلقه
والتي نناقش فيها ما نقلته وسائل اعلام
غربيه واكدت مصادر غربيه عن قيام طائرات
اجنبيه بقصف مواقع في داخل العاصمه
الليبيه وجهد اصابع الاتهام لكل من ابو
ظبي
والقاهره اعود الى ضيفي في واشنطن السيد
مارك ليفين ان كان ان كانت واشنطن كنا
تسالنا قبل قليل تعلم او لا تعلم بعض
المواقع قالت بان واشنطن كانت تعلم بهذه
العمليه ما هي الحسابات الامريكيه في فيما
يجري في ليبيا من باب المطالبه بعدم
التدخل العسكري ومن باب اخر انه لا يعنيها
من تدخل او لم
يتدخل اعتقد ان حكومه الولايات المتحده
كانت مندهشه ولا اعتقد ان لها علاقه مع ما
قامت به ابو ظبي والقاهره كنا متفاجئين
وكان العالم الغربي متفاجئا بما حدث وبما
يبدو
وكانه
قيام الامارات العربيه المتحده ومصر
بالهجوم لكن اعتقدوا ان الامر يعود للشعب
الليبي لاتخاذ قرار حول مصيره وليس لدول
المنطقه بان
تختار اي نوع من الميليشيات لكي تدعمها
اعتقدوا ان الموقف هش ولربما كان على
الغرب ان يبقوا لمده اطول
ام في الحقيقه في نهايه اليوم اعتقد ان
السلام والاستقرار
هو في مصلحه العالم الذي الذي وقع الان
بعد هذه العمليه ان ليبيا الان اصبحت
بحكومته ببرلمان واصبحت بجيشين وبالتالي
هناك مسؤوليه لاي تدخل غير مدروس في
ليبيا
نعم لكن هنالك حكومه واحده منتخبه انت محق
هنالك حكومتان وهنالك جيشان لكن هنالك
حكومه واحده تم اختيارها من الشعب الليبي
وهي الحكومه الشرعيه
هناك سيد طباق ماذا عن تداعيات هذه الخطوه
على المستوى القريب وكذلك على المستوى
البعيد التصور ان فيما يتعلق بهذا ال
الاعتداء السافر سيكون له جمله تداعيات
بدايه اتصور بان القياده المصريه ستراجع
حساباتها حيث حيث سيظهر لها بانها قد وقعت
في تلبيس من قبل طرف سياسي ليبي او همها
بغير الواقع مصر هي بيت العرب وهي كانت
دائما يجتمعوا عندها الليبيين نتذكر
التاريخ الليبي من عبد الرحمن عزام باشا
وغيره من رجالات القيادات المصريه التي
كانت تجمع الليبيين ولا تصطف في اطار طرف
على حساب طرف اخر ايضا اعتقد بان
محددات الواقع وهي قرارات ذات قرارات
امميه ذات علاقه بالخصوص كما اسلفت بدايه
من 1973 واحاطه السيد طارق متري يوم 18/3
2014 وانتهاء بالقرار الاممي
2144 تؤكد على حمايه المسار الديمقراطي
وحمايه السياده وال الوحده الوطنيه
الليبيه ايضا محددات الواقع
التي نشات حديثا على الارض هذه كلها ستكون
لها تداعياتها وقراءتها ما امله ما ما
امله ان
يتم مراجعه هذه السياسات وعوض خلق العدو
بغير بغير بغير مبرر سواء من قبل دولتي
الامارات وجمهوريه مصر العربيه
وال البحث عن قاسم مشترك لكل الليبيين وا
التواصل مع كل الاطراف عوض
عن معاداه فريق سياسي جراء توقع بانه يقاد
من قبل جماعه الاخوان المسلمين وهذا غير
صحيح
الاخوين في استاذ عبد القادر فقط واقعه بس
واقعه بس احب ان اذكرها بان من وقع
ضحيه الاعتداء السافر كان مجموعه من
الشباب الليبيين بعضهم من مدينه غريان
البعض الاخر من مدينه طرابلس والبعض الاخر
من مدينه مزرات وبعض اخر من مدن حول مدينه
طرابلس ولذلك كيف يمكن القول بان تيار
سياسي وهو تيار الاخوان هم جميعا في هذا
الباب وكان القصف يتعلق به كان يقبل
موضوعيا يقبل موضوعيا لو تم القصف على
جميع وصل وصلت الفكره
و المتصارعين يمينا الوقت س الوقت اعتذر
منك اعتذر منك دكتور حسن وسيله اعلاميه
اماراتيه دعت بشكل مباشر وقالت ودعت الى
عمل وتحرك عربي فوري من اجل القضاء على من
تصفهم بالارهاب وصنف فهم داعش والاخوان
وغيرها وقالت القيام بهذه الخطوه حتى دون
التنسيق مع دول جوار ليبيا او ما ينتج من
اجتماعاتها ما مدى خطوره هذه الخطوه
وتداعياتها في الوقت الذي ترتفع فيه
الاصوات للدعوه الى حوار داخلي
ليبي اعتقد ان هذه الفكره خطيره وان
الدعوه الى الحوار هي الفكره الاسلم وليس
لمصر ولا للامارات ولا لاي دوله عربيه اي
مصلحه على الاطلاق عدم استقرار ليبيا
المشكله يا سيدي ان اطرافا داخل ليبيا لا
تريد الحوار وتريد ان تقطع الطريق على
عمليه التحول الديمقراطي ولا تعترف
بالنواب الذين انتخبهم الشعب ولا تريد ان
تسلم هي الاطراف من هي
الدوله وبالتالي يعني يجب ان ان تكون هذه
الف ان تكون الاطراف الليبيه مقتنعه اصلا
بفكره الحوار حتى يمكن للحوار ان وانا احس
الطرف
المصري ان يعني يكون له صلات واتصالات مع
كل الاطراف وان يحاول ان يلعب دورا في هذا
الشان هل الان بامكانه ذلك بعد الذي جرى
ويجري نتمنى لكن الذي انت تريد ان تبدا
الازمه من
واقعه مشاركه الطيران اللي بتسهيلات مصريه
ولكني قلت لك ان المصريين تعرضوا بالقتل
داخل ليبيا قبل ان تتدخل ليبيا وبالتالي
هناك اطراف ليبيه بدات
عداء لمصر ويعني اهدت المصريين وادت الى
ربهم من ليبيا قبل ان يحدث اي تدخل عسكري
وبالتالي على هذا الطرف ان يعرف ان مصر في
دوله جاره وان مصر دوله ي لها حقوق يجب ان
تحترم وان يكون مستعدا للحوار واذا كان
مستعدا للحوار ففي هذه الحاله اتمنى ان
يعني تمد مصر كل الاطراف وان تحاول ان
تلعب دورا في يعني لم الشمل اشكرك دكتور
حسن نافعه استاذ العلوم السياسيه في جامعه
القاهره كما اشكر ضيفي من واشنطن مارك
ليفين كبير الباحثين في مشروع ترومن للامن
القومي وكذلك ضيفي من طرابلس صلاح الدين
طباق المحامي والناشط
السياسي بدا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج
ما وراء الخبر نلتقي باذن الله في قراءه
جديده فيما وراء خبرر جديد الى اللقاء
باذن
الله